thank you ashley a deadly shooting at a
new year's eve gathering in north las
vegas police calling it the first
homicide of the year this happened on
bruce street near the
i-15 in cheyenne 8 news now reporter
madison
kimbrough spoke to police about the
incident joins us now live with what she
can tell us hi madison
yes hello so this all happened at the
office building behind me i'm going to
let you guys get a closer look as we
zoom in
but it's still unclear which unit was
rented out for the party
now at around 4 15 this morning north
las vegas pd
received multiple calls about someone
getting shot
at this location on north bruce street
upon arrival officers located an adult
man unknown age suffering from at least
two gunshot wounds
medical personnel arrived and
transported the victim to unc
where he later died
according to police during the party two
people got into a fight over a gun
a third person stepped in with their own
gun and started shooting
currently there is a person of interest
to this crime but police haven't
released any information
we will of course keep you updated as
more information becomes available
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now